[Music]
it is true that dreams can become a
reality because our favorite Disney
cartoons are now part of our world in
live-action movies stay tuned until the
end if you want to know what is coming
next in 2019 if you love Disney movies
as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing new
Disney cartoons brought to life Beauty
and the Beast in 2017 we had the chance
to see Belle come to life in a story
that promised to be more feminist in the
original Disney movie
the young woman fell in love with a man
who was forcing her to stay in his
castle but emma watson who played Belle
said that this story was going to be
different we all know that the actress
is a proud feminist and she wasn't
interested in a story that didn't
portray strong women Belle knew how to
read she had a job and she refused to
marry a man she didn't like and even
when her father was captured she had the
courage to take his place and tried to
escape until she realized that she had
to simply face the situation Emma even
refused to wear a corset in Beauty and
the Beast however some people don't
agree with that and still think that
this movie is not feminists but that's
another story
Aladdin the cast of the live-action
remake of Aladdin has already been
revealed and people are upset that's
because Disney decided to brown up white
actors for non-white parts which is
called whitewashing people think that
it's an insult to the whole industry
because they should have given the roles
to actors from the Middle East but
actually the main actors aren't white
either Meena Massoud who will play
Aladdin was born in Egypt and raised in
Canada
Will Smith will also play the genie and
we can confirm that he is not white at
all even if they hired more than 400
background performers from India Middle
East Africa or Asia 100 of them were
actually white they just changed their
skin color to turn them into darkly
tanned Arab a Disney spokesperson said
that they only did this when it was a
matter of specialty skills safety and
control but many people in the industry
called this BS we hope that the movie
will be better than the choice of
backgrounds performers The Little
Mermaid The Little Mermaid always wanted
to be part of his world and now she will
be part of our world and they're
actually going to be three movies
not in the way you think first there is
the official Disney retelling composer
lyricist playwright and actor
lin-manuel Miranda says that he is going
to be working on this project but he
doesn't even know what he will be doing
they were still in super early talks in
fall 2017 then there is the universal
production aerials look was inspired by
actress Alyssa Milano and she was
supposed to be played by Chloe grace
Moretz but the actress dropped out of
the project along with many others so we
don't know what is going to happen next
and then there is a loose in the
adaption about a mermaid as it is the
only movie with a trailer we guess that
it's the only one you will have the
chance to watch soon Alice in Wonderland
can you believe that there were actually
17 adoptions of Alice Adventures in
Wonderland the first one dates back as
far as 1903 the eight-minute silent film
used impressive special effects for the
time and inspired filmmakers to be more
creative then there was the movie from
1931 Betty Boop also played the role of
Alice in 1934 and we saw another movie
in 1949 it is not until 1951 that we saw
the popular animated Disney movie this
story never stopped being popular as we
saw many versions of Alice whether it
was an animated or live-action movie for
kids or for grownups but it's in 2010
that we finally saw the best Alice movie
ever created as it was directed by Tim
Burton and featured Johnny Depp as the
Mad Hatter no matter how old you are and
what kind of movie you like Alice will
always be there for you Cinderella she
is probably one of the most famous
Disney Princesses as she inspired so
many rags-to-riches stories this is why
she decided to make a comeback in
Disney's live-action Cinderella in 2015
but when people saw how thin the actress
was in the live-action movie many people
were shocked some of them didn't even
want their kids to watch the movie they
didn't like how the director seemed to
think that women were more beautiful
when they had a waist the size of a
preteen while actress Lily James was
actually 25 years old at that time the
director defended himself by claiming
that it was natural with a little bit of
help from her corset but no matter what
many people think that any way to lose
weight to look unrealistic can't be
healthy The Lion King it was one of the
best disney movies of all time but
of us never thought we would see a
live-action movie of this because it's
kind of hard to July on how to act but
it has been confirms that we will have
the chance to see them on the big screen
and since the story is set in Africa we
are happy to see that they hired a lot
of african-american actors we have to
admit that our favorite is probably the
singer Beyonce who is going to play Nala
then we have Donald Glover who is going
to play Simba James Earl Jones he will
play Mufasa alfre woodard who will play
Surabhi and she we tell Ejiofor who will
play scar there are still white actors
but they are only going to play other
animals as we will see Seth Rogen and
Billy Eichner as Pumbaa and Timon and
John Oliver as Zazu Peter Pan you have
probably already seen a live-action
movie of Peter Pan and you will be happy
to hear that to see it's working on
another one the only thing we know for
now is that David Lowry will be the
director and he is going to help Toby
Hall Brooks write the script
the animated classic from 1953 is still
the most successful adaption of the
movie the movie hook directed by Steven
Spielberg and starring Robin Williams
wasn't even as good we think that a new
Peter Pan movie has the potential to
have even more success as a new
generation will discover this amazing
story it has been announced in 2016 and
we still haven't got any news yet so we
hope that they didn't forget this
project or maybe they're just busy
working on something else there is not
enough space in Neverland to shoot two
movies at the same time Tinker Bell
Peter Pan's best friend is going to have
her own movie it's going to be called
tink and we think that it's finally time
that this fun character gets more
attention this time Disney confirmed
that the movie is officially happening
and they even already cast the actress
we cannot think of anyone better than
Reese Witherspoon's to play this role
she has the beautiful blonde hair the
wonderful singing voice and she even won
an Oscar the only thing missing is a
green strapless dress the green slippers
and some wings she is also a little bit
too tall but we'll fix that with special
effects the actress is also producing
the movie which means that she will have
the chance to do whatever she wants and
be more creative as an actress we hope
that she will get the chance to play
Tinker Bell in the live-action Peter Pan
movie that Disney is supposed to be
working on Maleficent
we already heard the princesses story
now it's
to see it from a whole new point of view
by making the villain the hero of this
story they had the best team that could
ever find with Angelina Jolie as
Maleficent I script by the man who wrote
Beauty and the Beast The Lion King and
Alice in Wonderland and a director who
won an Oscar for his work on Avatar
however the story of the young
Maleficent was darker than what any
child could imagine she used to be a
little girl like any other until one
tragic event turned her into an evil
sorceress the man that she used to trust
took advantage of her while she was
unconscious and cut off her wings
according to the actress it was a
metaphor for a kind of assault that only
grownups could understand who thought
that they could show something like this
in a movie for kids Cruella De Vil and
here is another villain that we would
like to know more about but we were
really surprised to learn he was going
to play this role and the stone was in
talks to play Cruella De Vil in an
origin story but we did get she looks
and way too nice for this role and this
is why it's going to be really
interesting we've seen her wearing a
black and white dress a fur collar and
smokey eyes so we have already seen that
she really does have the look the movie
was supposed to go into production as
early as the latter half of 2016 but we
haven't heard of it yet we don't know
anything else about the movie come on
Disney you can't let us imagine in the
stone in the role of Parrilla to Vil and
just cancel the idea we want to see her
in this movie The Jungle Book
maybe Disney was just too busy being
nice with animals to create 101
Dalmatians once again that's because
they were working on Jungle Book the
filmmakers didn't want to use any real
animal on the set because it was very
hard to control them and these creatures
are not meant to work on a set this is
why they are all created with CGI the
sets were really simple like a small
hill or a short walkway and it's during
the post-production that they turned it
into something incredible it took a lot
of work six months of preparation and
two years of filming but it was totally
worth it however we can't imagine how
hard it would be for the actor to
perform with no partner on screen but we
don't think about that when we watch the
movie so we think that they did a really
great job Dumbo the small elephants with
the biggest ears is back once again and
in case you didn't get the chance to
meet him yet you won't want to miss this
opportunity to
this new movie that's because it's going
to be directed by one of the best movie
directors in the world Tim Burton he is
the one who already created the movie
Alice in Wonderland for Disney and many
other movies like Beetlejuice Edward
Scissorhands The Nightmare Before
Christmas big fish and much more the
production officially began in the
summer of 2017 while it is kind of hard
to make an elephant the hero of a story
the movie will include both live-action
and animated elements it has been
confirmed that the movie will be in
theaters in March 2019 and we can't wait
to see it but don't worry we'll get the
chance to watch other live-action Disney
movies during this time Winnie the Pooh
here's another animal that is soon going
to be part of our world and we think
that it's kind of hard to imagine our
favorite bear outside the animated world
that's why the movie will focus on
another character Christopher Robin he
is the little boy who befriended the
lovable bear in the animated series but
this time we will see him as an adult
some sources say that it will look like
the movie Ted and many people thought
that it was not the best idea if they
wanted kids to see it but don't mistake
it for another good movie another movie
titled goodbye Christopher Robin is also
in the works starring Margot Robbie and
domhnall gleeson we just hope that these
two movies won't be released during the
same year because too many people are
going to be confused Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs and we shouldn't forget the
first Disney Princess the last time we
saw Snow White was in 1937 and we can't
wait to see her again
in 2016 Erin Cressida Wilson was in
negotiations to write the script for the
film songwriters binge passuk and Justin
Paul who wrote the lyrics for lala land
will also be writing new music for
Disney then we have Marc Platt who is
already working on Mary Poppins returns
who will produce the movie we have
already seen reaching adoptions like
Mira Mira in 2012 and the Snow White and
the Huntsman but no one can do a better
job than those who made snow why popular
the creators who work for Disney and
they even won an honorary Oscar we can't
wait for that to happen again and they
have a chance with a live-action movie
about Snow White Mulan and last but not
least is a movie that we are going to
see really soon
that's Mulan live-action remake however
there will probably be no song in this
movie so Milan will have to find another
way to learn how to be a
moreover someone looked at the casting
and noticed that they were not looking
for a li Shang which means that they
might not be part of the story rumor
says that a European trader will fall in
love with Milan and some people are
really upset that li Shang might have
been replaced by a white man at least
there will be a lot of epic martial arts
the movie was supposed to be released in
2018 20 years after the first release
but it will finally be released in 2019
in November or December which movie
would you like to see the most don't be
shy to answer in the comments section
down below we'd love to hear what you
think and that's it for 15 Disney
cartoons brought to life if you liked
this video don't forget to subscribe and
please give us a big thumbs up thanks
for watching and see you next time